[Music]
i've watched the clip of you talking
about the martian i know you were
you were cut out of it so i i am curious
can you like walk us through what
happened
how many scenes did you shoot maybe
let's start there is it just one like
meaty scene that got cut
there was one talking scene dialogue
scene
i'm talking like i've never been on a
movie set before there's one talking
scene
there's one that i've seen i literally
um
how did i get here guys i don't know um
so there's one dialogue scene
and then i was like in scenes but just
like there
so there was this one dialogue scene
and i was it was this science jargon
and i it was you know ridley scott was
behind his
curtain and i was just mate
i just choked i just 100
and you know what i think it's so
important to just talk about
moments where you choke because they
really do inform
you know your experiences and they
really
do force you to kind of
reconcile whatever those insecurities
that you have
are and face them so i actually think
it's great and this is why i don't mind
i'm like yo
let me tell and anyone out there who's
like what in whatever field of work and
you think of that time
that you wanted the ground to swallow
you up let me tell you we've all been
there i've been there in front of ridley
scott
and i was i was joking
i couldn't get these words i couldn't
get these jargon words out
and um and i literally remember thinking
genuinely in my head you know that
phrase
i want the ground to like i wanted the
ground sword i'm out i actually want the
ground to swallow me up right now
um and you know we finally you know i
got
i got it i mean if they wanted to use it
they could have
i think it was probably a combination of
the fact that they didn't actually need
need it however the fact that i know i
was
like so nervous and that i choked
i probably was like in the back of my
mind i was like
yeah i don't know if i'm gonna make it
into this movie um
and then i went to the screen and then i
went to the screening the cast and crew
screening with my
with my best mate affair and i just
remember we were just watching watching
and i was like
when does my bit i'm sure my bit oh no
maybe it's after
no no no okay so now right so matt damon
he's safe now yeah i don't
okay i was just like oh okay
yeah yeah no i'm not gonna be after the
credits so
i think i'm not in it is it not typical
for them to warn you in advance
that was just a little i was just this
little roll they didn't care
so it's not like like maybe if you're
like the lead in something
that makes sense i wouldn't take that
stuff too personally
it just is what i mean it just i laughed
it off i came
back to my um my mother-in-law
this was the best this is the best thing
i am
i got back home went to hers
and because we were there and she opened
the door and she went
you're right extra
because literally in the movie i was
just like there's one shot of me in this
cap
and i'm like this it's like one second
i'm like
have you have you ever looked online so
you know how there's wikipedia
there's also like mini wikis for movies
and your character
has its own little wiki page and it's
the shot
i think of you and the hat
it's there oh my gosh there was
yeah oh gosh but it was a fun time i got
to go to budapest for a few days with my
cousins here
it was fun you know again you just you
learn
but generally i was like okay what
happened why was i like
and i realized i didn't think i deserved
to be there like i didn't i
i still to this day have moments of just
complete and utter imposter syndrome
of um just really
i'm not you know just how did i get here
how
you know i never grew up yeah i didn't
go to drama school i didn't and these
were by the way these are just
not things that i necessarily believe
and give credit but you know been
through
been through that and often you know
your mind does go back there you just
have to
continuously you know forge a different
kind of
neural pathway in terms of you know what
your mind goes to but
you know this idea of you know i wasn't
part of the in
i wasn't on the inside i felt like a
kind of outsider in that sense and
i didn't grow up reading shakespeare i
didn't do theater i didn't
you know i'd not you all of these things
that just play on your mind in terms of
like oh that must mean
i'm not a real actor you know where i'm
not or i haven't done
and and you but
i mean the more that you realize that
the more time you spend doing that the
less time you actually
you actually spend you know figuring out
learning and growing and actually
becoming the artist that you
want to become and not just the artist
that you think you should be
ari oh i should be like this person or i
should be all these people that you
you look up to and you think oh how do i
you know how do i get there but just the
version of yourself
now more than ever ever there is
so much appetite for specificity
and and and i mean that by not just
specificity in terms of
the content that we watch but
specificity in terms of
journey of how you got there as a writer
actor director
there's no one way yours can be unique
and lean in to
lean into your uniqueness but i have to
tell myself that
i have moments where i'm just like i
cringe at the thought
oh i was going through old emails the
other day like from 2013 and i was going
what was i doing what on earth was i say
like who does that what am i going on
about
you know you just think yeah you you do
still have moments and um
but i think for me i just i just try not
to focus on that and i try to go
why am i doing what i do forget all the
other stuff
i want to be better i want to be better
i want to get better i want to work with
people that are better than me i want to
work with you know great people
i want to be a part of things that i
really believe in and things that i
that explore humanity in some way and
um and there's there's not to say you
can't do that in the context of a big
poppy movie and
you know i i i feel so blessed that i've
been
a part of these you know these these
types of movies and
um it's a it's a skill in itself you
know that being being a part of that big
machine it's not
um it comes with its own challenges but
um
definitely you know moving forward um
it is just about you know who i'm
working with and what i'm saying with
what i'm doing
is kind of the most the most important
thing for me so that's kind of
i don't know how i got to where i got to
just now
you